et pour en parler alexis trou de
chercheur en géographie en géopolitique
spécialiste des balkans est avec nous
par téléphone
[Musique]
alexis trout bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
on lisait nouveau sommet entre les
membres de l'union européenne et les six
pays du balkans occidentaux
alors on entend perspective européenne
élargissement efforts conjoints ou
encore coopération aujourd'hui très
clairement quelle est la position de
l'ue eux sur cette question de
l'adhésion des balkans occidentaux
alors lui est très timide sur cette
question là on parlait beaucoup
d'élargissement rappelez-vous puisqu'il
ya encore quelques années on n'en parle
plus le est dans une position attentiste
elle parle de coopération est par
exemple ce qu'elle propose aux pays
balkanique qui négocient comme depuis
plusieurs années depuis 2000 touche pour
un service 2014 pour la macédoine n'est
que de piètres
consistance par exemple et elle ne
comprend pas la réalité des terrains par
exemple la crise du président elle
propose de vacciner or un appât confie
que la serbie par exemple à vacciner
parce qu'en plus que la france ou
l'allemagne donc ciblé elle ne voit pas
et la situation sur place et les besoins
ont ces pays balkaniques et et en même
temps le sommet doit approuver le plan
économique et d'investissement de 30
milliards d'euros pour des constructions
nouvelles infrastructures dans dans la
région s conclut ivoire à un autre
console autre consolation finalement une
volonté des vingt-sept de s'affirmer
dans la région alors je parle a par
contre un peu plus de finir par les
autres pensionnaires sur nantes et même
un plan assez conséquent mais je dirais
il répand il serait temps
rappelez vous les hommes le corridor
faire inquiéter des autoroutes liés aux
tuyaux énergétique crise européenne
avait voté en 1989 et bien non pas été
réalisés ça s'est un temps pour les
attend or en face la russie la chine
avance très très vite la chine a pour
deux milliards d'euros et le projet le
plus or tant financièrement dans les
transports en europe et bien est en
train de moderniser la ligne belgrade
la tête et or d'environ peine donc
alors justement du côté de l'albanie de
la bosnie et du kosovo du monténégro et
de la macédoine du nord ou encore de la
serbie est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
volonté de se tourner vers l'est après
les chiffres que vous venez nous nous
indiquer
oui alors ces pays sont tous dans une
position assez surprenante
par exemple à le faire si une politique
de neutralité elle veut absolument
rentrer dans l'union européenne
dans l'otan simplement si on a en tout
cas rentrer dans l'ue européennes et en
même temps elle se rapproche traces de
très rapidement de la russie tashi tout
même de pays orientaux comme la turquie
et l'iran
les autres pays sont citant cette cité
soins au savoir des balkans sont
historiquement et politiquement très lié
à l'europe ils ont des valeurs
démocratiques qu'ils ont démontré à
plusieurs reprises mais à force
d'attendre les européennes repousse un
peu des piles à faire clair leur
alliance
[Musique]
la russie la chine les pays du
moyen-orient
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
pandémie la chine ou encore la russie
ont été proches un des pays du balkan
par exemple on peut parler de cette
production services vaccins chinois et
russes finalement l'union européenne
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas déçu dans la
région par son manque de solidarité
qui si par exemple au mois d'avril
dernier le président wilczyk à une
déclaration à fait étonnante aux non
européens elle a dîné je n'ai pas besoin
de d'acta ropéen nous avons tout ce
qu'il faut il faut savoir que la série
là le cheval de troie de la chine en
europe produit autant de vaccins que un
pays comme l'allemagne et donc sur les
lignes européennes se montrent un peu
donne aspect beaucoup trop timoré par
rapport aux enjeux
on se range aux stratégies les
autoroutes et les routes énergétiques
par exemple la russie a ouvert en début
d'année le fameux gazoduc nord stream
qui marchent à plein pendant que
européenne l ai dit tout à l'heure n'est
pas encore prête à développer les fameux
corridor européens et les wc en 1999 du
coup à quoi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
comme décision après ce sommet entre les
pays des balkans occidentaux et les
dirigeants de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui
alors comme il ya deux ans à une
solution de compromis c'est-à-dire ce
plan d'investissement qui voit la team
important permettra aux dirigeants
locaux
d'afficher leur leurs liens avec les
valeurs occidentales mais en même temps
politiquement une sorte de deux
seins de feuilles de non-recevoir
signalé à ces pays là puisque on leur
dit qu'ils ne rentreront pas avant 2028
ou 2030 or d'ici là quid de l'union
européenne et
et surtout le cibler les groupements
politiques sur place comme un protégé
grade comme une île schengen on avance
et on a un dernier exemple le plaisant
de faire 10 août chips avec le président
erdogan qui était l'idée des gaullistes
de bosnie ont créé un mythe schengen
donc ciblé pilote milan européenne
attend tron est bien et pays là iront
vers de plus en plus de structures
centres européenne au revoir elle est
européenne
merci beaucoup alexis troude pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes chercheur en
géographie et géopolitique spécialiste
des balkans